rede darüber ob die hypo welt zum
download freigeben wird
hey leute herzlich willkommen zurück zu
einer weiteren folge minecraft ihr auf
dem hexe server ich kontakte mal eben
und werde in dieser folge weiter hinten
häuser bauen und auf eure twitter fragen
eingehen
ihr könnt nämlich zwei twitter folgen
twitter.com search von crafter wenn ihr
bei solchen frage sessions dabei sein
wollt so hier werden
jetzt hab ich ja auch schon dieser
komischen bugs da habe ich konnte ja
noch keine kommentare lesen weil ich ja
am vorproduzieren bin für die nächsten
tage weiterhin nicht so viel sein werde
und zwar werde ich auf eure twitter
fragen näher eingehen tag gamer us
findest du dass du berühmt bist das ist
immer so eine frage als was man berühmt
mehr oder weniger halt definiert ich
definiere berühmt dass man von allen
möglichen personen in allen bezirken in
allen lebens schichten in allen
lebenslagen und in allen orten irgendwie
in irgendeiner form erkannt wie das ist
für mich immer so ein bisschen das
bedeutet für mich halt berühmt sein
können wir hier
64 davon und das bin ich definitiv nicht
also ich sage euch freunde das einzige
die einzigen personen die mich bisher
erkannt haben dass ist auch also er hat
hier geschrieben das ist keine rast
frage gilt es ist auch klar dass es
keine frage ist aber dass erst dazu
schreibt die einzigen orte an denen oder
die einzigen personen die mich bisher
erkannt haben waren alle komm her waren
alle so jung hat alle 13 14 jahre alt
würde ich schätzen
das ist jetzt auch nichts gegen
reichardt also ich finde es gut dass ihr
meine videos guckt auch in so jungem
alter halt aber daran sieht man halt
schon dass nicht nur diese leute
erkennen also wenn ich jetzt zum
beispiel durch die stadt laufe dann
erkennen mich wenn ich durch ein wenig
findig hamburg mal letztens gelaufen
wegen rooneys weiter gucken und mit zwei
freunden da mich glaube ich fünf leute
erkannt als ich sechs sieben stunden am
tag in der stadt waren die bahn hat alle
relativ jung
ich glaub ich hab mich hätten noch mehr
leute er kann also es haben noch mehr
immer so rüber geguckt zu kinder kinder
also ja auch schon erwachsen mehr oder
weniger aber die haben mich halt dann so
angesprochen und es hat wir waren
wirklich nur junge leute deswegen wenn
ich berühmt wäre wenn ich sagen würde
ich bin berühmt
dann müsste nach meiner theorie müsste
hätten mich auch so leute ansprechen
müssen wie alle zwei minuten müsste
irgendeiner zu mir hin kommen dann meine
oma da man kind dann man ein
jugendlicher dann mal eine mutter oder
irgendwie so und sagen hey du bist doch
hier der bla bla bla so das sind dann
für mich so berühmte leute sind für mich
so joko und klaas oder im deutschen raum
wenn er noch zu fußball auf jeden fall
die so von jedem äckern werden jeder
irgendwie kennen schon mal gesehen hat
das sind für mich berühmte leute nicht
ich der da so ein paar abonnenten auf
youtube hat und videos für jugendliche
macht das ist ja dass er auf keinen ich
will mich auf keinen fall als berühmt
ansehen alles andere aber nicht berühmt
man hätte das bei mir so pseudo
berühmtheit also berühmt in der eigenen
reihen so nennt ich hab so definiert als
berühmtheit aber nur in der eigenen
branche mehr oder weniger also in den
leuten die das wirklich mit der mit der
mit der mit dem mit der materie vertraut
sind die man halt macht
hiermit kann ich nichts machen schade
mit
damit wird so ein bisschen was würdest
du tun wenn es keine spiele geben würde
ohne witz das muss man halt auch wieder
definieren was heißt jetzt keine spiele
heißt keine spiele jetzt auch nicht so
etwas wie brettspiele und all so was wie
schnick schnack schnuck dann will ich
mich die mich umbringen wenn es keine
chance gebe bestehe aber erstmal darum
kann ich erst mal das dings draufsetzen
natürlich ich fahre aber dass wir auf
jeden fall
ich könnte es nicht mehr leben weil ich
spiele nahezu den ganzen tag also was
heißt ich zock ich natürlich ohne
computerspiele und ohne play sowie ich
natürlich schon über liebe ich würde
auch so eine spiele überleben aber ich
meine wenn wir zum beispiel ein
typischer samstag ist einfach ein kumpel
kommt zu mir wird seine runde fifa dann
fahren wir los und spielen fußball wird
so echten sport auch nicht gäbe sind ja
auch quasi spiele dann fahren wir los
und spieler fußballer trainieren wie
sowas dann meistens treffen uns mit
anderen leuten spielen dann auch fifa
und das witzige dabei ist es gibt ein
laufspiel alle von euch die schon
trinken dürfen
train alkohol ihr könnt ja mal einfach
ein fifa spiel gegen den kumpel machen
und immer wenn irgend wie er sagt zum
beispiel okay du hast wenn jetzt
dortmund gegen bayern spiel du hast
götze mandzukic und ribery und der
andere hat dann zum beispiel reis
schmelz an weidenfeller
und immer wenn diese namen genannt
werden ich glaube davon rechnen immer
wird einer dieser namen genannt wird
muss man halt was trinken solche spieler
machen hat immer um zu trinken oder
meier oder so ein paar leute sagt euch
das bestimmt was
dieses wird alles nicht geben deswegen
ich weiß nicht das ist das wird alles
nicht geben das aber ich denke jetzt
wieder so ja damit könnte man ruhig
schon überleben das geht ja relativ
simplen unsere blabla ja aber jetzt im
moment ist einem das gar nicht so
bewusst es fällt einem quasi erst auf
wie wertvoll einem die ganzen spieler
sind wenn man es denn wirklich verliert
das ist auch so wenn man sich den arm
bricht
ich hatte meinen arm die ganze zeit halt
normal normal funktions tätig also jetzt
beide auf funktion tätig hat mir zweimal
gebrochen
in einem jahr jedenfalls wenn ihr jetzt
denkt so mein arm euro schlepper der arm
der funktioniert das ist will ich dann
sds dank sicher keiner von euch jeden
morgen wenn man aufsteht
oh mein abend funktioniert mein ganzer
körper funktioniert schön danke dass ich
leben darf
das sagt ja keiner hat es ist einfach
ich freue mich die ganze zeit ich weiß
gar nicht wo ich bin
das sagte er niemand niemand sagt dass
deswegen niemand ist ja auch
verständlich ich sage jetzt nicht dass
ihre tätig dafür bedanken soll dass ihr
lebt aber man sollte schon jeden tag so
genießen und so bleibt ist das so und so
aber man mehr quasi erstes einem etwas
fehlt wenn's weg ist wenn man ihnen die
freundin hat oder wenn eine freundin
jungen hat oder sondern der junge macht
schluss
der mac die freunde dann erst wie viel
wirklich wert war oder so wenn man dann
irgendwie abends alleine vom feld keine
ahnung oder beim arm ist halt so dass
wenn man sich dann die zähne putzen da
muss man einfach mit links machen oder
wenn man duscht muss man sich auf eine
verdammte mülltüte bei den abend ziehen
weil der armen sonst der darf nicht nass
werden wenn du es eingibst rum ist
deswegen das ist halt das feld einfach
so weg ist und so ist es halt glaube ich
auch mit den spielen möchte auch gar
nicht so aus aber jeder frage effekt
schon dass ich psychologie studieren
werde
welchen namen soll deine kinder haben
habe ich auch schon mal gesagt uns
finden und selena sind meine beiden
lieblingsnamen auf jeden fall jetzt
clowns wieder alle irgendwelche
14-jährigen schlappen und euch jetzt
kinder bekommen finanzpläne das hat zum
thema youtube gesagt könnt ihr durch
machen ich finde die namen echt mega
geil megageil das ist falsch
123 okay so jemand hat nämlich noch
einmal hin und hier müssen die vier
hunde befinden uns hier den nach wenig
sind die schönsten namen die ich je
gehört habe
deswegen sollen meine kinder auf jeden
fall für uns lena heißen
also ich packe mal wieder ein paar
sachen die ich erst mal nicht mehr
brauche ich auch nicht gehen die händler
davon noch mit hier schönste mensch dort
zwar was haben wir sonst noch so wir
haben hier noch wie findest du dass du
im durchschnitt eher junge zuschauer
hast ja gerade schon geredet mir ist
eigentlich relativ egal wie alt die
zuschauer sind hauptsache sie gucken ist
derzeit nicht so hauptsache ich klicke
auf die wir aber um diese dann ihr gebt
mir klicks und so sondern hauptsache ich
kann leute damit unterhalt das ist egal
wie alt sie sind
hauptsache ihr habt da irgendwas in dem
ihr unterhalten werden und dann ist es
ja egal wer zuschaut ist natürlich ein
bisschen doof in der schule jetzt vor
allem dass da immer leute sind die
hinter ihm herlaufen und so will ich mit
meinen freunden warum laufen und dann zu
sagen
kontrakte und dann gucken sie schnell
weg und so und kichert sich damit den
freunden ab das ist mégane rs ist
nervigste auf der welt dann wenn man
manchmal nicht einfach nur hingehen und
den ihn zu sich kam das ist echt einfach
so manchmal etwas trägt denn was heißt
manchmal trägt ein immer heftigst auf
aber gut das sind die schattenseiten des
berufs
nee das ist ein bisschen nervig aber
deswegen da will ich dann sagen dass
eventuell leute die ein bisschen älter
sind unter schauen würde die würde dann
halt die privatsphäre respektieren und
die kennt das halt noch nicht
die jungen leute dass man da halt
wirklich nicht gestört werden möchte
wenn ich im urlaub bin oder mit freunden
unterwegs bin ist das klar dann könnt
ihr von mir aus zu mir hin kommen sagen
hey aber in der schule ist das echt so
nervig dann schreibst du da gerade eine
klausur geschrieben bis mega fertigt der
server so gucke ich drücke aber jetzt
geht das gar nicht so geschrieben bis
mega fährt die leute an
also ich denke das ist verständlich
meine meinung in dem fall falsch gebaut
habe ich so was will ich sein
so wird es da oh verdammt so soll das
dach nämlich werden debatte nämlich so
manche kommen nämlich dass holzen und
hier kommt marble hin
aber dafür muss ich erst mal kurz das
hier bauen und ihr da also was habt ihr
sonst noch so mit wie vielen jahren hast
du angefangen zu zocken
mein ganzes leben ohne witz man spielt
wirklich sein leben das leben ist ein
spiel für mich ich habe so richtig
angefangen ein erstes spiel war super
mario world of nintendo gameboy advance
was er damals noch das war mal in mein
erstes spiel was ich so gespielt habe
und da musste mein vater mich damals
weiterbringen die hatten level
hingekriegt was ich nicht hingekriegt
hat das war so komisch da habe ich mich
richtig beleidigt gefühlt hat das
erstmal eine woche nicht gespielt weil
ich dachte nein mein vater kann viel
besser als richtig doof und so aber
danach immer mehr gespielt
ja also ich denke so mit sieben war das
oder so richtig angefangen zu zocken
wie findest du dass das im dach des
pavillons schon dann magst du am
wenigsten aus dem das heißt auch nicht
wenn ich am wenigsten mag aus dem
eu-projekt ich mag alle eigentlich weil
ich mit allem was zu tun habe ein paar
leute denke ich mir mal so etwas machen
hier ist wieder für kaka aber oder wat
soll dat partie das machen aber das ist
halt eher selten der fall
bist du gut in der schule oder eher
schlecht kommt darauf an wie man gut und
schlecht definierten wenn man jetzt sagt
man ist gut mit einem 4 1 schnitt das
ist natürlich eine komplett andere
definition als wenn ich sagen würde man
ist gut wenn man überhaupt hin geht oder
11 oder irgendwie so also ich kann sagen
ich habe im schnitt von 24
und ich bin eigentlich zufrieden also
ich würde sagen okay das ist für dich
das mein abi schnitt versuche ich 20
hinzukriegen dass natürlich will ich
wenn ich es schaffen würde
aber sonst würde ich erst mal sagen das
ist ganz ok meine eltern immer noch
höher da geht noch was aber dass meine
eltern ja immer aber sonst jahr 2,4
müsst ihr selbst definieren ob das als
gut findet dafür dass ich recht wenig
tool für die schule finde das echt ok
freunde wieder ein bisschen hier 14 uhr
ergebnisse was willst du nach us-
projekt machen hat das hat mir grad
schon
der letzten folge wie lautet der
wahlspruch der ccp mit wem werdet ihr
frieden schließen habe ich schon gesagt
wir schließen frieden mit denen die
angegriffen werden und was unser
wahlspruch ist ist man charaktere kennen
keine ahnung schreibt mir mal
wahlsprüche in die kommentare dass sich
irgend coolen spruch habe oder so auch
man ändert kann es nicht sein wie ich zu
blöd berner dem wort diese teile banken
auch runde ich scheiße freue mich jetzt
drauf das ist ihm also doppelt und
dreifach und keine ahnung
magst du fußball ich liebe fußball kommt
kraft der love you i love you too
das wird die ccp verändern aus allen
häusern wenn es gute gründe sind ein
hashtag vccp alle hashtag ccp in die
kommentare schreiben mal wieder hier
damit wären in den rocky lee davon
überzeugen dass er auch wählen soll
ja es wird natürlich einmal die häuser
verändert das ist das wo ich gerade
schon dabei bin
die natürlich sehr sehr hübsch aussehen
wie ich finde wir müssen wir schreiben
wir die findet also bisher das hier ist
jetzt fast fertig das haus hier
da kommt auch noch ne band rein und
sauber so werden die häuser aussehen ich
finde ich habe so ein bisschen in dem
flyer gebaut wie das hier schon ist ein
bisschen mit diesem mut gemacht aber
sonst werden so in etwa dann die häuser
aussehen und sonst sind die restlichen
sachen habe ich ja schon in folge 90 92
was glaube ich gesagt in der folge von
vorgestern habe ich auch schon gesagt
was die leitsätze leitsätze leitzins
werde leitzinsen senken
damit packe ich ja nur investoren aus
deutschland weg aus dem pop reggae dann
investiere mir leid sind so hoch ist
besser so so wenn du jetzt reisen
könntest wohin würdest du reisen zur
zeit
ich weiß nicht ob ich nach amerika
reisen würde
weil der held justin bieber ist da hab
ich halt nicht so bock drauf
nein ich würde echt mega gern mal nach
amerika oder nach australien hätte ich
auch mega rock aber eigentlich ja auch
falsch gebaut hier so rede darüber ob
die hypo welt zum download freigeben
wird
das weiß ich nicht das muss man simon
fragen ich denke am ende des projektes
jahr sowie bei minecraft beta projekt
wird es dann gleich werden
warum hast mit youtube angefahren
auf youtube dein leben verändert hat ja
im moment ich meine durch youtube habe
ich leute kennengelernt die ich so nie
kennengelernt hätte das ist halt so
die hauptsache an der ganzen sache die
hauptsache die ganze sache also es macht
auf jeden fall mega viel spaß
ich habe das ganze schneiden
kennengelernt die internetpräsenz ich
beschäftige mich vielmehr mit dem medium
internet was das jetzt hier schalte ich
habe gelernt einfach frei sprechen zu
können dass ich jetzt einfach so wenn
ich jetzt hier bin solo sprechen könnte
ist es besonders gut gegen welche
vorstellungsgespräch wie viel ich da
wirklich sprechen kann das sagt mir
jeder und sonst halt glaube ich auch
dass es für meinen weiteren werdegang in
beruf und so auch nicht wichtig ist
nicht alles sagen kann hier das habe ich
vor zulegt das ist glaube ich ganz gut
und dadurch hat das mein leben halt
immens verändert deine erfahrungen mit
frauen nicht so drüber reden kumpel
formiert der hat keinen kanal mehr
aber er hat mal video gemacht ganz
damals wurde über
übers [ __ ] gelabert hat und der hat
musste ihn wie alle videos unternehmen
weil die ganzen mädels ihnen das
gefunden haben und wie gesagt hätte du
vollidiot wertete oder zeige bekommen
möchte ich nicht überreden so was haltet
ihr sonst auch so der untergrund und
kinder haben frieden macht das denn
nicht den über grund überflüssig hatte
über grund ist allgemein überflüssig nee
ich bin ja eh nur so halb über grund
gewesen
ich war ja nur eigentlich mal kloster
war einfach nur so ein bisschen
unterstützen die ist dass man habe ich
den satz von der seite ich erst mal
fertig das muss ja immer gucken ja sie
ganz gut aus hier aus sieht gut aus so
ihr sieht auch ganz gut aus auf
wunderschöne wieder
aber hier auch ja sehr schön sehr schön
wunderschön so hier auch perfekt schlägt
man habe hier ja sieht auch ganz gut
ganz neues außen usb zu schnell
ja sie auch ganz schön ausschauen ist
keine von oben an soja ja hab ich hier
alles voll mit diesen teilen oder sich
über welche übrig abgezählt so hier ist
ja jetzt hier fehlen
so so hier haben wir aber auch alles
voll hier ist auch alles voll so hier
ist auch alles voller schön dass es blöd
dass die farbe ein bisschen anders ist
das jetzt ein bisschen dunkler allgemein
aber naja sie auch ganz schön aus ihr
müsst ihr aber leider wieder weg gibt es
auch weil da die anderen teil dahin
kommen sondern baut man jetzt das dach
weiter und währenddessen beschäftigen
wie mit der frage von dass es zum ärger
vieler safina war hast du ein vorbild
wenn ja wen
hier steckt habe ich vor bilder
eigentlich habe ich mir vorgenommen die
vorbilder zu haben weil man sonst zu
stark beeinflusst wird
aber sonst jetzt auf mein leben bezug
ich glaube es ist auch mein leben
besonders wird sie schreiben hast du
lädst player als wir das irgendwie noch
von youtube als vorbild oder so auch
mein leben bezogen habe ich als vorbild
wird habe ich denn ich habe mehr respekt
vor dem
hier von diesem einen der diese links
studie hat ich habe keine ahnung wie der
heißt die märkte schon auch ich dachte
ich schaffe es noch im flug bahn
electric stuff zu nehmen aber es war
schon zu spät
von diesen typen der nach der
eingewandert ist nach deutschland vor
allem eine kleine chance etwas reißt und
jetzt hat er irgendwie das größte
flugunternehmen oder irgendwie sowas ich
weiß nicht genau wie der typ heißt
vielleicht könnt ihr auf die sprünge
helfen denen den habe ich als vorbild
dass man halt alles erreichen kann egal
an welcher stelle im leben ansteht und
sonst auf youtube bezogen habe ich als
vorbild sechs cap finde ich mega witzig
finde ich mega cool was die machen ja
sechs kämpfe nicht ganz billig so hatte
sind die fenster überhaupt so überhaupt
so über über überhaupt zu über über
überhaupt so über 90 minuten bei 19
minuten leute lieben freunde was es dort
für eine kacke
ich kann ja nix schaffen mensch ich weiß
nicht ob ich noch eine folge dran hängen
soll
am liebsten würde ich echt einfach jetzt
pausieren weil ich schon mega fertig bin
und ich gleich noch mitkommen ich muss
mit komme auf nämlich kann ich noch eine
folge dranhängen verdammt geil
leute ich hoffe euch hat es gefallen wir
können wieder beziehen und haben sich
mit bekommen hö nie lassen wir das wir
sehen dass hier aus auch mal toll davon
natürlich aber kein bill stewart ja das
fühlen da war einfach ein bild oder
warte doch habe ich wieder diese kg hin
doch das ist falsch
da kommen die hier nämlich hin kommen
darüber hier fenster und hier kommt er
rein oder und hier oben kommen auch
wieder diese teile drauf oder komm mal
wieder fackeln dran und dann wird so in
etwa dann später ein haus aussehen
also ich hab jetzt ich bin ein bisschen
weiter gekommen wieder werden auf jeden
fall viel geschafft würde ich sagen und
ich habe auch über viele themen geredet
in den nächsten folgen wäre ich dann
meine kisten alle weghauen und die
häuser zu ende weiterbauen und sonst
würde ich sagen meine lieben freunde
wenn es euch gefallen hat schreibt
hashtag pcp in die kommentare und lässt
am besten bewertungen da wenn ihr
zuhause das einzuschreiben
natürlich sagen